make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today's episode of beyond omega-level is
going to focus on the DC side of things
as we're going to be discussing volthoom
the first Lantern novel Foom was created
by Geoff Johns and made his first
appearance in Green Lantern annual
number one in 2012
now as for his origin story both Foom is
a scientist from earth 15 where he and
his mother actually discovered the
emotional electromagnetic spectrum which
is the force made up of all the emotions
and all sentient beings within the
multiverse it contains all the various
emotions that power the various Lantern
rings now as to begin learning about
this spectrum both doom and his mother
created a device called the travel
Lantern which allowed them to travel
through time and space and across
dimensional boundaries and when earth 15
was invaded by a hostile alien race both
whose mother was killed but before she
died she told him to use the travel
Lantern to try to find a way to save
their people now just before the planet
was destroyed full Foom does as she says
travels back in time and makes his way
to various earths looking for a way to
save his home planet and his species and
so voloom makes his way through the
multiverse using the travel Lantern but
he isn't able to make any progress in
finding a way to save his people along
the way he stops on earth three and
encounters a sorcerer named mordru and
exchanges a part of his soul to create
the first power ring which would become
known as the ring of Old Firm which
would eventually end up being wielded by
power ring the evil Green Lantern of
Earth 3 and later on Jessica Cruz now
finally both who makes his way to the
main DC Universe and encounters the
guardians of the universe in ancient
species of highly intelligent beings who
have created a power battery that they
call the great heart by filling it with
all their emotions believing that
reading themselves of emotion would
allow them to devote all of their
intellectual capacity to scientific
discovery and understanding of the
universe from there what we see happen
is that a ring is created by performing
a ritual in the great heart in voloom
wields the ring becoming the first
Lantern to exist in the entirety of the
DC Universe now initially both Doom
functions as a sort of universal
peacekeeper much in the same way that
the Green Lantern's later would but
during this time the guardians would
eventually place the great heart into
volthoom chest which allowed him access
to the entirety of the emotional
spectrum he ends up making a deal with
the Guardians whereby he agrees to help
them perfect the technology of the great
heart and the first ring in exchange for
allowing him to take it back to earth 15
and save his home planet however things
begin to go awry one
the exposure to the emotional spectrum
causes volthoom to lose his sanity and
to try to murder the Guardians and so
eventually the Guardians with the help
of the first seven Green Lantern's they
create are able to destroy whole foods
travel battery stripper mode the first
ring and the great heart and imprison
him in the chamber of shadows a cell
that was thought to be inescapable but
not before he was able to kill thousands
of guardians and so volthoom
would remain imprisoned for billions of
years but of course would eventually be
released and upon his escape we get to
see just what it is that mole Foom is
capable of and so as far as powers go
because he is essentially the living
embodiment of the entire emotional
spectrum both doom is a being of immense
power whereas each of the Lantern Corps
is able to master one single emotion
along the spectrum such as the Green
Lantern's with willpower or the Red
Lanterns with rage volthoom
is able to manipulate every emotion on
the spectrum simultaneously the
potential damage that can be achieved
through this connection to the emotional
spectrum was what led the Guardians to
conclude that imprisonment was the only
option for volthoom
as he represented a threat to all of the
multiverse and in fact his escape from
the confinement produced hairs in the
very fabric of reality now like all
members of the various Lantern course
both doom is able to create constructs
but he differs from the rest of the
lanterns and that while their constructs
are simply made of hard light volthoom
constructs are real which means that
both doom is able to warp reality which
in turn means that he's definitely
beyond an omega-level threat volthoom
also possesses incredible telepathic
ability and was even able to invade the
mind of ganthet one of the guardians of
the universe who himself has formidable
telepathic powers both oome is also able
to manipulate time and was able to force
the Guardians into multiversal
hypothetical timelines against their
wills both doom is also a being of
incredible durability having survived
injuries that would kill mortal beings
as well as surviving an attack from the
combined forces of most of the various
Lantern cores including the White
Lantern Kyle Rayner now volthoom is also
able to create powerful energy blasts
and has been able to defeat Atrocitus
with one shot and take out an entire
army of black Lantern's by himself on
another occasion both doom declared
himself to be a god and literally stomps
parallax into the ground now parallax
flows you guys who don't know is the
literal embodiment of fear in the DC
Universe so the fact that both Foom is
able to stop him is a
how do we impressive but really
shouldn't be surprising since fear is
but one emotion on the spectrum la voix
Foom is the embodiment of the entire
spectrum furthermore because volthoom is
essentially the embodiment of the
emotional spectrum he is effectively
immortal as we learn when he asked
Metron to kill him what we learn is that
since the emotional spectrum is powered
by the totality of emotion of all
sentient beings in the universe as long
as there are beings in existence capable
of feeling emotion both whom must exist
he can be separated from his physical
body for a time and necron was able to
do that when he appeared to kill both -
but eventually he will resurface which
makes him essentially immortal and all
that is impressive enough but the most
impressive thing we've seen from both
doom was that he held the universe in
his hands and almost remade it in its
entirety
the fact that he was not successful in
remaking it in accordance to his will
notwithstanding the fact that he could
have done it if not been thwarted by the
combined efforts of several lanterns
including the White Lantern Kyle Rayner
still qualifies him as well beyond
omega-level because he has the potential
to work reality on a universal scale so
yeah full phoom is ridiculously powerful
a definite universal threat and likely a
multiversal threat as well at least when
he's in possession of the travel battery
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explain and make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and that will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you